et justement réindustrialiser la france
pour réduire aussi sa dépendance de
l'extérieur une nécessité pour la
plupart des candidats à la
présidentielle d'eric zemmour 1 fabien
roussel en partant en passant par
valérie pécresse les pénuries de masques
et de respirateurs au plus fort de la
crise du coc vides ont laissé un mauvais
souvenir aujourd'hui l'heure est donc à
la red réduit industrialisation mais
s'en donne t'on vraiment les moyens
comment industrialisés un pays comme le
nôtre qui s'est vidée de ses usines au
fil des décennies on en parle tout de
suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
seller de l'édito est qu
un bon soir jacques sapir la
réindustrialisation c'est pas facile a
dit hun sen va être au coeur de la
campagne présidentielle
si on croit évidemment les programmes de
quasiment tous les candidats oui tout à
fait et d'ailleurs il faut bien dire que
emmanuel macron lui-même mouiller sa
chemise avec en particulier le programme
france 2030 qui annonce des objectifs
relativement ambitieux maintenant il
faut comprendre aussi que on ne pourra
juger et jauger de cette ré
industrialisation que si on comprend
qu'elles sont les mécanismes qui ont
poussé à la désindustrialisation
depuis maintenant une trentaine d'années
alors tout d'abord dans quelle mesure la
france et d'un dea industrialisés alors
il faut bien voir que c'est d'abord sur
le l'emploi qu'on le voit le plus on
voit que l'emploi industriel et en
particulier on le voit sur le graphique
qui s'affiche c'est dans les industries
d'équipements autrement dit les machines
dans les industries de transport par
exemple l'automobile l'aviation et c'est
que les pertes d'emplois ont été les
plus importantes par contre
effectivement pour l'industrie
agroalimentaire il ya une relative
stabilité d'emploi mais dans tout ce qui
est je dirais la partie noble de
l'industrie il ya des pertes d'emploi
tout à fait considérable alors est ce
qu'on peut dire que la concurrence
internationale a eu un effet déterminant
sur ce phénomène oui certainement même
si ce n'est pas le seul effet il faut
pas tout mettre sur le dos de la
concurrence internationale est là et on
le voit sur cette autre graphique on
voit très bien qu'à partir de 2003 bien
sûr nous continuons à exporter
toujours plus de machines puisque là ce
sont uniquement les importations et les
exportations industrielles mais nous
apportons beaucoup plus et se creusent
un déficit commercial spécifique à
l'industrie qui explique par ailleurs je
dirais l'immensité abyssal du déficit
commercial français actuel alors est ce
que cette désindustrialisation n'est pas
un phénomène en définitive générale dans
tous les pays développés
c'est vrai il y à une
désindustrialisation partout mais ne se
fait pas au même rythme et ça c'est
important regardez là on voit sur ce
graphique nous sommes tombés aujourd'hui
en france a grosso modo 12% pour le
poids de l'industrie dans le pib des
pays comme l'espagne ou l'italie se
retrouve au-dessus de 15% l'allemagne
elle même au dessus de 22% alors bien
sûr l'allemagne était dans les années
1970 à 36% donc elle est passée de 36 à
22 mais nous nous étions à peu près à
26% et nous sommes passés à 12% donc
gérer que proportionnellement la baisse
en france est vraiment beaucoup plus
importantes y compris plus importante
qu'en italie et en espagne la question
c'est quelles en sont les causes est ce
que le fait de ces fameux impôts de
production dont on parle tant pendant
cette campagne présidentielle alors il
ya à l'évidence un problème de coût et
ce en dépit des aides que l'état de nos
entreprises et en particulier aux
entreprises industrielles et le montant
de ces était absolument pharaonique 120
milliards d'euros par an c'était le
chiffre en 2018 bon va pas tenir compte
du chiffre de 2020 évidemment avec le
quoi qu'il en coûte il a beaucoup monté
mais en 2010 820 milliards d'euros 5 5%
du pipe en aide et là on voit bien il ya
deux grandes masses dans cette aile il
ya d'abord le cic le crédit d'impôt pour
la compétitivité et l'emploi et l'autre
chose ce sont les exemptions d'impôts
que ce soit des exemptions qui sont
liées aux charges sociales ou que ce
soit des exemptions fiscales qui
représentent elles aussi 40 milliards
donc c'est tout à fait considérable et
par rapport à ça si on prend maintenant
le poids des impôts de production mais
on voit qu'ils ne représentent qu'eux
son mode ou 2% du pib 2,15 pour cent en
réalité c'est à dire grosso modo 50
milliards 50 milliards c'est quand même
moins que les 70 milliards d'elle et si
on supprime les impôts de production ce
que veulent de très nombreux candidats
de valérie pécresse à eric zemmour eh
bien ça ferait
170 milliards dead pour les entreprises
je suis désolé ça coûte un pognon de
dingue et s'il y a des assistés en
france c'est plutôt les entreprises
alors que se passe-t-il alors ce qui se
passe et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que il y a deux raisons
fondamentales
on voit là le choix de l'étranger le
seul choix de l'étranger il est évident
les entreprises françaises ont choisi de
délocaliser pour échapper à des impôts
et pourtant on a vu l'ampleur des aides
qu'elle recevait mais aussi à cause du
coût du travail et on voit que les
entreprises françaises qui se sont
internationalisées
elles ont pratiquement les deux tiers de
leurs emplois hors de france alors que
la proportion est évidemment nettement
plus faible en allemagne est beaucoup
plus faible en italie ou en espagne
alors donc que fait-on pour rien de se
réaliser alors c'est vrai que c'est une
question qui va être délicat et on voit
d'abord qu'il ya un problème évident de
taux de chance
rappelez-vous le premier graffin le 2ème
graphique qui s'est affiché à l'écran on
voyait bien que cette espèce de déficit
commercial spécifique à l'industrie il
avait démarré en 2003 donc on voit bien
c'est une conséquence de l'euro est
aujourd'hui l'écart de taux de change
entre la france et l'allemagne est
devenue absolument insupportable de ce
point de vue là il faut quand même se
souvenir que quand on avait la
possibilité justement de
dévaluer le franc si oui si on se remet
à cette époque l'un est bien qu est ce
qu a fait le général de gaulle en 1958
où nous avions un problème qui était à
peu près du même ordre il a déprécié le
franc de 37% en deux opérations une en
juin 58 l'autre en décembre 58 même
chose en 1969 après la crise de 68
qu'est ce que fait le président pompidou
et giscard d'estaing qui est à l'époque
son ministre des finances eh bien il des
prix si le franc de 11% mais dans le
même temps l'allemagne réévaluent le
deutschmark autrement dit là encore ça
fait un choc de compétitivité 2 22% donc
oui c'est un véritable problème et puis
derrière il faudra bien que l'état à un
moment donné contrôler les grandes
stratégies des entreprises est bordé il
n'est pas possible pour des raisons ne
serait-ce que stratégique que vous
continuiez à délocaliser au niveau où le
fait et c'est ce qu'on voit justement se
profiler dans les programmes des
candidats alors c'est pas exactement ce
que l'on voit il ya un tabou en france
il faut le savoir c'est le tabou de logo
personne ne veut toucher à leur odeur
c'est un petit peu différent avec la
situation de 2017 et tant qu'on ne
touchera pas alors autant qu'on ne
posera pas la question de l'euro est
bien en réalité on ne pourra pas
réaliste réalisé de manière réellement
efficace et puis il ya un deuxième
problème
il faudrait que l'on recueille
reconstitue l'équivalent de ce qui était
autrefois le commissariat général au
plan la ruine nous avons un haut
commissaire au plan mais ce haut
commissaire au plan françois bayrou il
fait d'ailleurs bien son travail mais
qu'est-ce qui fait comme travail il fait
un pur travail de prospective
non le plomb devrait si on veut vraiment
réindustrialiser définir des voix de
réindustrialisation et surtout contrôler
la stratégie des entreprises en fait le
seul espoir qui nous reste c'est
justement le plan nucléaire qui a été
annoncé donc dans le cadre france 2030
par le président emmanuel macron parce
que on peut espérer qu autour de ce
développement de l'industrie nucléaire
eh bien on est une cristallisation des
autres entreprises industrielles merci
beaucoup jacques procès me en garde et à
la semaine prochaine avec olivier nokere
en flac et puis à dans deux semaines
avec moi merci à vous